está probado se convierte en ley y se
gira al poder
[Aplausos]
esta manera argentina finalizaba el año
2020 haciendo historia al convertirse en
el primer país más grande de américa
latina' en despenalizar el aborto bajo
todas sus causales la nación
sudamericana convirtió así en ley el
proyecto de interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo hasta la semana 14 de gestación
presentado por el presidente alberto
fernández y transformó en derecho un
reclamo que hace años millones de
mujeres exigen en el país
le damos así la bienvenida a la
entrevista de france 24
en esta oportunidad nuestra invitada al
igual que muchas de sus compañeras tuvo
un rol clave y trascendente en lo que
fue el debate que se dio en la cámara de
diputados- su discurso cerró una sesión
de más de 20 horas de debate y fue uno
de los más fuertes inmovilizadores de
aquella jornada y de hecho trascendió
las fronteras de argentina y circula
ahora por países como colombia y españa
entre muchos otros
ella es gabriela cerrutti diputada por
el bloque frente de todos pero antes de
saludarla los invitamos primero a ver un
fragmento de su discurso en aquella
histórica jornada
pero no es una novedad que este mundo es
injusto no es una novedad que en este
mundo hay miseria no es una novedad que
este no es el mundo que queremos lo
sabemos perfectamente las mujeres porque
durante siglos nos obligaron a parir
para mandar a nuestros hijos a la guerra
para explotar a nuestros pibes en las
fábricas durante siglos nos obligaron a
parir para mirar para el costado cuando
los pibes crecen en la pobreza y así
como hoy se conmovían todos con los
derechos y el milagro del embrión no los
veo conmoverse igual cuando mataron pibe
de 14 años por la espalda lo que venimos
a pedirles hoy es dejen de hacer del
cuerpo de las mujeres el territorio de
disputa de aquello que no pueden
solucionar la economía o la política el
mundo es injusto efectivamente pero la
respuesta no está en nuestro útero solo
vamos ahora ciega a abrirlas arruti a
quien escuchábamos recién en su discurso
en la cámara de diputados que abrirá
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 es un placer
como estas buenas tardes muchas gracias
por haberme llamado y por haber pasado
estas imágenes que desde el día de hoy
que las seguimos escuchando y nos ponen
la piel de gallina y nos conmueve pero
estas pibas allá en la calle y vernos a
nosotros no que son tantos años somos
hijas herederas de otras luchas y
llegamos finalmente a lograr esto que es
un hito más en muchas luchas que hemos
venido dando y que vamos por supuesto a
seguir dando por la igualdad de las
mujeres por la autonomía sobre nuestros
cuerpos y sobre nuestro deseo
absolutamente grave la vuelvo a
agradecerte tu presencia france24 algo
muy interesante y que veíamos no en tu
discurso es que colocas el tema en un
contexto histórico muy amplio no el del
sometimiento durante siglos de los
cuerpos gestantes al sistema de
producción y también al sistema político
voy a citar que también hemos ido de la
mano de obra barata que sostuvo este
sistema en el último siglo dijiste en tu
discurso una fuerte crítica del sistema
basado en la explotación de las mujeres
y también de la naturaleza no desde esta
perspectiva gabriela hay una conexión
directa no entre el modelo económico que
sostiene al mundo la explotación de la
naturaleza y la opresión de las mujeres
verdad
si nosotros tenemos una mirada que viene
claramente desde el ecofeminismo ya no
es solamente que queremos trabajar
debatir deconstruir la explotación de
las mujeres sino que entendemos que la
explotación de las mujeres en el
capitalismo y el patriarcado ha ido de
la mano de la explotación de la
naturaleza y eso hace que este mundo y
este no solo sea profundamente injusto
hacia las mujeres sino que también
estemos enfrentando la crisis climática
y enfrentando el peligro de extinción no
de la cantidad de de tapiz de la parte
de biodiversidad y de tàpies de la
tierra que va a ser la vida muy difícil
y creemos profundamente que esto tiene
que ver con un modelo que está basado en
que hay que producir más y consumir más
y que de hecho cuando sucede lo que lo
que vivimos este año que es una pandemia
mundial y el mundo tiene que detenerse
en un momento colapsa la economía con lo
cual evidentemente hay algo de ese
sistema económico que no funciona y es
un sistema y ahí vemos de nuevo a las a
las pibas dando esta pelea que hoy las
mujeres y las pibas y los cuerpos
instantes como bien decías venimos a
plantear que lo que queremos no
solamente es igualdad lo que queremos no
es solamente esa autonomía sino que lo
que queremos es cambiar este sistema por
un sistema más
para todos y todas gabriela otro punto
muy fuerte de tu discurso tiene que ver
con la cuestión del deseo no te voy a
citar lo que dijiste nos pasamos toda la
noche discutiendo porque a veces hay
embarazos no deseados pero no discutimos
en toda la noche lo que sí deseamos
porque cuando un embarazo no deseado es
porque se desean otras cosas y el
verdadero conflicto está con esas otras
cosas que se desean no decías voz en
aquel discurso que trascendió al país
podemos decir que recién a partir de
ahora en el año 2021 las mujeres o mejor
dicho como decíamos los cuerpos
gestantes de argentinas pueden elegir
sus proyectos de vida no solo si quieren
ser madres o no
y eso también tiene que ver con la que
vos decías antes de que hemos sido la
mano de obra barata de este sistema
durante siglos y yo decía en el discurso
construyeron sus fábricas sus fortunas
sus negocios porque nosotros estábamos
en la casa cuidando hijos cuidando
padres cuidando a maridos de honor nada
de todo eso el capitalismo ha funcionado
haciendo que las mujeres fuéramos las
que nos ocupábamos de reproducir el
sistema de reproducir y de tener varones
para que fueran a la guerra para que
fueran a las fábricas para que fueran a
trabajar mientras nosotras cuidábamos
este todo eso es tan importante que es
cuidar toda la vida familiar es las
mujeres entre los 30 y los 40 años nos
tenemos que ocupar de nuestros hijos y
también de nuestros padres porque
tampoco está pensada la vejez en este
nuevo mundo graves y cada vez más larga
de qué manera vamos a hacernos cargo de
una vejez auto válida y más larga y
entonces cuando decimos el embarazo no
deseado estamos deseando diciendo bueno
que si deseamos y lo que deseamos es
salir de ese lugar que la historia nos
había puesto que es el dormitorio y la
cocina hace quinientos años que las
mujeres hemos sido relegadas a estar en
el dormitorio y la cocina y la verdad es
que queremos decidir qué proyecto de
vida
es tener que mundo queremos habitar de
qué manera queremos hacerlo y para eso
las discusiones son profundamente
políticas y profundamente económicas hay
cuando yo decía este no es nuestro útero
el problema no vengan a tratar de
solucionar disputando sobre nuestro
cuerpo lo que no puede solucionar la
política y la economía la política de
economía tienen que dar respuesta a una
cantidad de cosas y las mujeres somos
parte de esa discusión no queremos estar
relegadas tampoco de esa discusión y ver
cómo se prepara un mundo cada vez más
injusto para todos y todas entonces
ahora este es un proceso que viene de
muchas conquistas previas no hay que
seguramente augura futuros logros somos
las hijas de las locas del pañuelo
blanco dijiste en referencia a las
abuelas y las madres de plazo de mayo y
dijiste también somos las madres de las
locas del pañuelo verde en aquella
sesión maratónica en la que hacíamos
referencia y también son por supuesto
gabriela voz sobre todo la generación
que en los 80 salió a pelear por la
democracia no hay un cruce generacional
y puente no con diferentes luchas pero
que se van conectando entre sí
conquistando derecho a verdad
yo creo que sí y dejamos estar muy
orgullosa de la lucha de las mujeres de
la argentina que históricamente han sido
las que han salido a la calle cada vez
no solo que tuvimos que pelear por los
derechos de las mujeres sino también por
los derechos de la sociedad fueron las
madres las abuelas de plaza de mayo las
que salieron a la calle y se enfrentaron
con la dictadura militar y buscaron los
cuerpos desaparecidos y buscaron a los
nietos apropiados por la dictadura
militar fueron las mujeres piqueteras
las que armaron las socias populares en
las crisis del 2000 son las pibas los
que desataron sus pañuelos verdes en las
mochilas desde secundario pibas muy muy
jovencitas y han hecho de esta marea
verde algo que ya está avanzando por
todo el continente porque sabemos que
sigue la lucha y que sigue la pelea que
va a llegar a colombia y que va a llegar
a chile y que vamos a lograr realmente
que este continente deje de tener esa
impronta tan fuerte tan conservadora tan
marcada por el poder de la iglesia
católica durante tantos siglos desde la
conquista en adelante que nos ha hecho
estar muchas veces teniendo que luchar
mucho más que en otros países por
determinadas conquistas y derechos y si
la verdad es que es en esa unión en ese
altar de español en las novelas porque
también cuando las madres de plaza de
mayo salieron a la calle
eran las locas de la plaza las locas del
pañuelo blanco y las pibas este han sido
muy muy estigmatizada son muy
maltratadas y ahora son las pibas del
pañuelo verde y en este en este altar de
pañuelos vamos tejiendo la historia las
antes tras las pioneras las que hoy
están en la calle vamos haciendo que el
mundo siga girando de alguna manera
absolutamente y gabriela esa
transversalidad no se da entre
diferentes generaciones de mujeres
solamente sino también entre mujeres de
diferentes bloques políticos opuestos
incluso por ejemplo a favor del proyecto
votaron incluso mujeres de partidos más
conservadores como el pro como
interpretadas esa unión en la diversidad
yo creo que hay algunos sectores que no
son conservadores sino que son liberales
entonces son conservadores en lo
económico pero liberales en lo político
y además hemos logrado construir tiene
que actuamente que hay derechos que van
más allá como los derechos humanos como
los derechos de la mujer o los derechos
de la identidad como los derechos de las
personas trans que no tienen que ver con
una postura política pero también déjame
decirte una cosa que es que yo creo que
deberíamos ser capaces de encontrar esa
transversalidad también en otros temas
yo no estoy tan segura de que personas
que pertenecen a diferentes partidos
políticos no estemos o no podamos estar
de acuerdo en que este mundo tiene que
ser un poco más equitativo y un poco más
junto entonces seamos capaces de
sacarnos de encima esas etiquetas que
también nos ha impuesto de alguna manera
este sistema patriarcal este sistema de
construido verticalmente de arriba hacia
abajo en el que tenemos que estar de un
bando o tenemos que estar del otro aquí
en la argentina hablamos permanentemente
de la grieta y si son un lado no son del
otro y la verdad es que los temas que
tienen que ver con la condición humana
con la búsqueda de la feliz
con la búsqueda de la igualdad y la
justicia muchas veces no hay no hay
grieta que nos separe sino que tenemos
que ser capaces de estar de acuerdo de
ponernos de acuerdo y de hecho las
mujeres lo hemos logrado y me parece que
podemos dar un gran ejemplo en eso de
cómo es una construcción circular una
construcción soro ahora una construcción
colectiva en la argentina en el
continente y también dialogando
permanentemente con el feminismo de todo
el mundo yo creo que el feminismo es el
gran sujeto político la gran sujeta
política de esta de esta época que viene
a cambiar la manera de hacer política no
esto queremos ocuparnos sólo de los
temas de las mujeres queremos ocuparnos
de todos los temas y por eso queremos
desde paridad en los gobiernos en los
medios de comunicación hasta este diría
en la cultura y en el arte porque esto
de la desigualdad no es algo que quede
encasillado en un lugar sino que hemos
tenido que dar esta pelea absolutamente
en muchísimos lados los mismos
territorios y la vamos a seguir dando
gabriela nos quedan menos de 30 segundos
más o menos nada más pero quería no
quería dejar de preguntarte cómo lo
viviste más allá de tu rol como
funcionaria a nivel personal
mira digo yo lleva adelante un aborto
voluntario en el año 95 cuando era muy
jovencita tenía 26 años tengo dos hijas
de un hijo y una hija y tuve abortos
involuntarios obviamente y siempre digo
que la gran diferencia entre el aborto
voluntario y el involuntario es el deseo
muchas veces uno se queda mucho peor
después del aborto involuntario que una
voluntario básicamente porque la estaba
buscando y lo estaba deseando en este
momento y este debate fue también la
oportunidad que muchas pudimos hablar
con nuestras chicas de nuestros propios
abortos de los de nuestras madres de los
de nuestras abuelas y correr el velo del
secreto familiar también me parece que
es una novedad muy importante que
traemos a la política y yo viví esto con
con mi hija en la plaza mis hijas en la
plancha con sus amigos y entonces
realmente ese abrazo generacional nos
hace ilusionarnos aunque estamos
construyendo un mundo más justo para
para de alguna manera resarcir dolores
pasados de otras generaciones pero para
también para dejarle un mundo más justo
a nuestros hijos gabriela cerrutti
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24 ha sido realmente un placer
gracias por la entrevista y muchas
gracias no por favor ya en nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informando en el resto de
nuestra población y en france24 punto
com
[Música]